thank you
this has become an important part of the
Russian war machine Kamikaze drones made
in Iran
video from Ukrainian police shows
officers shooting down one Iranian drone
but another made it through hitting a
high-rise apartment building in Kiev
killing four people Iranian drones have
bombed Ukraine relentlessly in recent
months capable of striking targets far
from the front lines they are designed
to be used only one time is designed to
inflict the maximum damage
Damien spleacher's team of weapons
investigators analyzed the wreckage from
Iranian drones in Ukraine and made a
troubling find we discovered that they
were heavily reliant on on Western
components and Technology he says more
than 80 percent of Iranian drone parts
were actually produced by companies in
Western countries including the United
States and Canada
[Applause]
Global News traced one case involving
allegations of trying to send drone Tech
to Iran to this home near Toronto hello
look like oh is Vader here
no who's this Vader faki is facing
federal charges in the United States the
Indian citizen moved to Canada in 2010
and launched his own Consulting business
and tech company
according to the U.S charges between
2017 and 2018 faki and his brother tried
to obtain highly sensitive pieces of
equipment for a Tehran technology
company that supports Iran's military
including counter drone technology and
an industrial microwave system which the
U.S says can be used to create
high-powered energy weapons
faki's brother allegedly requested an
agent fee of 20 000 US dollars for their
help procuring the equipment writing in
an email that the company in Canada is
taking a huge risk we're here from
global news we're just someone to talk
to him foxy wasn't at home and did not
respond to our list of questions
eventually reached by phone he declined
to comment on the advice of his lawyer
the charges against him have not been
proven in court according to this U.S
indictment faki's brother was arrested
by the Americans 18 months ago and has
since pleaded guilty to violating U.S
sanctions against Iran faki is also
wanted by American authorities but he's
been living and working freely here in
Canada and even applied for Canadian
citizenship are you surprised to hear
about a case like this I'm not surprised
I know that people with ties to Iran's
regime operates in Canada last October
the Prime Minister announced what he
called the most robust and comprehensive
sanctions in the world against Iran that
is why today we're using the most
powerful tools at our disposal to crack
down on this brutal regime Banning
thousands of regime members from
entering Canada and restricting
Financial transactions there seems to be
a real mismatch between the government's
rhetoric and its actions a Canada Border
Services spokesperson said dozens of
people with ties to the regime and its
revolutionary guard the irgc had been
denied entry to Canada but none had been
deported we're not seeing any movement
on the reports we've made
um in the sort of identifying irgc
members this Refugee lawyer and activist
says police lack resources
ottawa's announcement last year included
76 million dollars for sanctions
enforcement but the RCMP says it hasn't
yet received the funds the irgc has been
circumventing uh International laws for
decades they've become good at it
they're able to
operate through proxies in Focus case
U.S prosecutors say Iran tried to evade
sanctions by sending the money first to
Dubai then to faki's Canadian company
vaki allegedly purchased the equipment
for Iran from a company in Massachusetts
and tried to export it to Dubai but the
shipment was intercepted by U.S
authorities
Iran's weapons support for Russia in
Ukraine is made possible by its ability
to evade Western sanctions adding
urgency to calls for Canada and others
to crack down Jeff sempel Global News
Toronto